DAZHI PENG: Hi, guys, there are some other big news in tech industry going on this week.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, some are exciting. Some are depressing. The exciting news is that open AI release its latest multi-model Gd. 4 model
Jeffrey Feng: Well, less capable than humans in many real world scenarios, except it's human level performance on various professional and academic benchmarks. For example, it passes a simulated bar exam with a score around the top. 10% of test takers in contrast, Gp 3.5 score was around the bottom 10%.
Yooni Choi: This was so exciting. Can't you imagine what Gpt. 4 can do since Chat ipt is so powerful Already I have been using chat to extensively for my everyday work.
DAZHI PENG: if it is so powerful, according to open the Igbt for succeeding in the most recent public, the available test in a case of all linked and ap free response questions.
DAZHI PENG: all by pretty in 2,022 to 2,022 to 2,022, and they did No.
Jeffrey Feng: yeah. I think what's more exciting, that Gbd 4 can even accept visual. Inputs. There was an example on opening a website that the user asked.
Jeffrey Feng: What's funny about this image? Describe it panel by panel
Jeffrey Feng: and Gp for successfully identify all the interesting features of that image.
Yooni Choi: Given these features, I think it's definitely worthwhile for us to do a deep dive into its capabilities. Dr. Would you be able to read open AI's technical report for Gp: 4 and present a summary of it to the team.
DAZHI PENG: Yeah, I gotta do that.
Jeffrey Feng: Thank you. At the same time the bad news in the tech industry that matter starts another round of layoffs since last November. I think, Matt, I plan to lay off about 10,000 employees, or, roughly, 13 of its workforce.
Yooni Choi: That's a lot of people. I remembered Meta already laid off 10,000 employees last year. The layoffs will affect me as recruiting team this week with a restructuring of its tech and business group to come in April and May. Mr. Zuckerberg set in the email posted on the company's website.
DAZHI PENG: I also heard this lay of you involved with all the methods, may have limited layer of management people.
DAZHI PENG: All right, Ernie's calling properly the chief and the group that he did no one the company to be overst with the of management or managers managing managers.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, this is an interesting question for us to investigate as well.
Jeffrey Feng: Whether too much middle management people are actually helping or hurting the company.
Yooni Choi: It makes sense, because Meta has kept changing from Meta verse to AI, or vice versa. There is definitely something wrong with their leadership structure.
DAZHI PENG: There you need. Can you email me whether the management it's helping us in the Company efficiency.
Yooni Choi: Yeah, sure. Maybe other tech giants like Amazon or Google, or experiencing the same problem.
Jeffrey Feng: This was an interesting discussion. Have a good week, guys.